one of the great things about science is
that when scientists make a discovery
it's not always in a prescribed manner
as in only in a laboratory under strict
settings with white lab coats and all
sorts of neat science gizmos that go
peep in reality the events and people
involved in some of the major scientific
discoveries are as weird and varied as
they get my case in point the weird
history of the cell theory there are
three parts to the cell theory one all
organisms are composed of one or more
cells to the cell is the basic unit of
structure and organization and organisms
and three all cells come from
pre-existing cells to be honest
this all sounds incredibly boring until
you dig a little deeper into how the
world of microscopic organisms and this
theory came to be it all started in the
early 1600s in the Netherlands where a
spectacle maker named Zacharias Jensen
said to have come up with the first
compound microscope along with the first
telescope both claims are often disputed
as apparently he wasn't the only board
guy with a ton of glass lenses to play
with at the time
despite this the microscope soon became
a hot item that every naturalist or
scientist at the time wanted to play
with making it much like the iPad of its
day one such person was a fellow
Dutchman by the name of Anton van
Leeuwenhoek who heard about these
microscope doohickeys and instead of
going out and buying one he decided to
make his own and it was a strange little
contraption indeed as it looked more
like a tiny paddle the size of a
sunglass lens if he had stuck two
together
it probably would have made a wicked set
of sunglasses that you couldn't see much
out of anywho once leaving Hooke had his
microscope ready he went to town looking
anything and everything he could with
him including the gunk on his teeth yes
you heard right he actually discovered
bacteria by looking at dental scrapings
which when you keep in mind that people
didn't brush their teeth much if at all
back then he must have had a lovely
bunch of bacteria
look at when he wrote about his
discovery he didn't call them bacteria
as we know them today but he called them
anima cules because they looked like
little animals to him
well even Hooke was staring at his teeth
gunk he was also sending letters to a
scientific colleague in England by the
name of Robert Hooke Hooke was a guy who
really loved all aspects of science so
he dabbled it a little bit of everything
including physics chemistry and biology
the Siddhas Hooke who we can thank for
the term the cell as he was looking at a
piece of cork under his microscope and
the little chambers he saw reminded him
of cells or the rooms monks slept and in
their monasteries think college dorm
rooms but without the TVs computers and
really annoying roommates Hooke was
something of an underappreciated
scientist of his day something he
brought upon himself as he made the
mistake of locking horns with one the
most famous scientists ever Sir Isaac
Newton remember when I said Hooke
dabbled in many different fields
well after Newton published a
groundbreaking book on how planets move
due to gravity Hooke made the claim that
Newton had been inspired by Hookes work
in physics Newton to say the least did
not like that which sparked a tense
relationship between the two that lasted
even after Hooke died as quite a bit of
Hookes research as well as his only
portrait was misplaced
due to Newton much of it was
rediscovered thankfully after Newton's
time but not as portrait a sadly no one
knows what Robert Hooke looked like fast
forward to the 1800s where two German
scientists discovered something that
today we might find rather obvious but
helped tie together what we now know as
the cell theory the first scientist was
matthias schleiden a botanist who liked
to study plants under a microscope from
his years of studying different plant
species it finally dawned on him that
every single plant he had looked at were
all made of cells at the same time on
the other end of Germany was Theodor
Schwann a scientist who not only studied
slides of animal cells under the
microscope and got a special type of
nerve cell named after him but also
invented
rebreathers for firefighters and had a
kick in Paris sideburns after studying
animal cells for a while he too came to
the conclusion that all animals were
made of cells immediately he reached out
via snail mail as Twitter had yet to be
invented two other scientists working in
the same field that was schleiden it got
back to him and the two started working
on the beginnings of the cell theory a
bone of contention arose between them as
for the last part of the cell theory
that cells come from pre-existing cells
slidin didn't exactly subscribe to that
thought as he swore cells came from free
cell formation where they just kind of
spontaneously crystallized into
existence that's when another scientist
named Rudolf Virchow stepped in with
research showing that cells did come
from other cells research that was
actually how to put it borrowed without
permission from a Jewish scientist by
the name of Robert remark which led to
two more feuding scientists thus from
teeth gunk to torquing off Newton
crystallization to Swan cells the cell
theory came to be an important part of
biology today some things we know about
science today may seem boring but how we
came to know them is incredibly
fascinating so if something bores you
dig deeper it's probably got a really
weird story behind it somewhere
Oh